happening today nearly a third of the
House GOP conference will get a
firsthand look at the growing border
crisis when they visit Eagle Pass Texas
Crossing after a record
302,000 migrant surge last month and 7
million over 7 million since Biden took
office as Biden doj asked the Supreme
Court to get this let them remove razor
wire put up by Texas authorities and
it's cost them 11 billion to do what the
federal government Won't Do by the way
our next guest is one of those GOP
lawmakers visiting the Border today
joining us live from Texas with a
preview Congressman you've been down
before you don't need a primer but what
you need is what you have you need
specifics on what you need in this deal
on the border correct on Asylum changes
border finishing the technology tell us
what you're looking for well we need the
legislation we passed several months ago
that would fix the problem but if
they're not going to do that then just
do one sentence one sentence change that
sentence is real simple no money can be
be used to process or release into the
country any new migrants stop the
problem right now just say we're not
going to do call a complete timeout
because Brian understand the magnitude
of the problem is as you said 300,000
last month a record month but the Biden
presidency is on Pace at the end of his
four years he will have allowed into the
country when you took about the Goda
ways and everything else 12 million
illegals 12 million migrants coming
that's the equivalent of the entire
population of Ohio the seventh largest
state that is the magnitude of the
problem and of course we know the cause
the cause is the Biden Administration
and their crazy policies that they
adopted on day one and it continues
today with the doj saying take down the
razor wire Texas just let them keep
coming in we want to we want to go even
more than 12 million for goodness sake
so the solution is really I think one
sentence the question is do Republicans
have the will to fight for that one
simple sentence which says we're going
to fix this problem right uh you you
actually and you know this but anyone
you have something you rarely have you
have leverage because he wants the he
wants the money for the wars uh for
Ukraine uh potential war in Taiwan and
Israel and a lot of you guys are on the
same Pages at would you say not until
the Border it's fixed including guys
like Lindsey Graham who think all three
conflicts are worth financing he knows
nothing changes without that and he
could lose all three during the next
year here's what President Biden said
last night
listen
me the money I need to protect the
Border he says he needs the money he
goes get him the money to protect the
Border it's not the money it's the will
remember what he did on January 20th
2021 he changed the three policies from
the Trump Administration that were
working he said no more building the
wall no more remain in Mexico while we
evaluate your claim and he said when we
get you when you come in you will be
released no detention no detaining these
individuals no returning them to their
to their native country so when you make
those three changes there people who can
fall people for wanting to come to the
greatest country ever they just keep
coming and as I said the magnitude of
this problem the country now fully
understands even Democrat Mayors in
Chicago and New York understand how
serious this problem is will we have the
will to do it will Republicans say no
you're not getting the money for X
unless you do that one sentence or
Implement House Bill two the legislation
we passed would which would infect um
would deal with the problem I know
you've been the house getting brief
regularly but right now on the Senate
side lankford's leading the Republican
cause he said they met throughout the
break except for Christmas and Christmas
Eve have you been briefed on anything
encouraging or
discouraging no I mean we we we follow
the briefings in the Press I've talked I
talked with you know speaker Johnson
last night because he's down here
leading this trip um but we haven't got
anything new we'll see what what they
come up with but understand we're not
going to fund Ukraine unless it actually
solves the problem on the border I think
the simplest the simplest solution is
the one i' I've just offered which is
that one what one basic sentence just
call it and the president can do this on
his own we know he won't so we should
fight for that one sentence we should
fight for hr2 that's how we solve this
problem but you see Congressman I got to
let you go here too I know you got to
get out to the Border but the thing
that's different is you have a war
between the cities and states he never
anticipated a blue State and a red State
fighting but really on the same page
when it comes to the Border needs to be
enforced that's additional leverage that
you have Mayors turning on the president
who are now turning on Governors he's
ripping this country apart by ignoring
something that's vital to our national
security uh Congressman don't let up you
have leverage please use it you bet
thanks Brian you got it I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis